hey greg gunn here you might recognize
my voice from the future podcast
which if you aren't already you should
totally be listening to
look for one of those little fly out
links in the top right corner
okay so a while back our friend leo made
this wonderful typography video for us
it's an animation of 10 graphic design
rules to help improve your typography
and with over a million views i'd say
it's done pretty well
but what's really impressive about it is
the way leo showed how those rules work
using motion design we asked how he made
it
and he was gracious enough to show us so
with his permission
and my narration here's how leo built
the animated typography
manual here we are in adobe after
effects
where all the magic happens leo's going
to show us how he built the first
animation from the video
and here's what that looks like for
reference we see the zero and the one
form
then the camera moves through the zero
and as it moves
we start to see a paragraph of text come
into focus when the camera rests
we see that right justified text change
and move across the screen to become
left
justified looks easy enough but let's
see how leo does it
to start we're going to create a new
composition and
since this is the first typography rule
we'll name it 0 1 and set its resolution
to 1920
by 1080. okay now let's set the frame
rate to 25 frames per second
the duration to 5 seconds and the
background color to black
we'll hit ok and that will create the
composition for us
now let's make our type we'll start by
using the text tool to create the zero
we can scale it up by dragging one of
the corners but just like in other adobe
apps
you can fine-tune your type by going to
window characters
and opening the character menu and by
doing so we can see that leo is using
helvetica new
for this demo now he's going to show us
how to reveal the zero
as if it's drawing itself onto the
screen we'll start by clicking the pen
tool
but make sure that we don't have any
layer selected
this will create a new shape layer we
can then use the pen tool to kind of
trace the contour of the zero
it works the same way as it does in
adobe illustrator
now the goal here is to create a mask
that we can then
animate to reveal the zero but we need
to make sure that it completely covers
it
and to do that we'll go back to the
selection tool
click on the curve and increase the
stroke width
there now it's covering the full
thickness of the xero
to animate that reveal we'll need to add
a path animation
so let's select shape layer 1 twirl down
the layer properties
and then click the add button to add a
trim path's property to the layer
allows us to animate the start and end
positions of the stroke we just made
if we change the start value you can see
that the stroke is trimmed
okay now let's click the stopwatch icon
next to end to set a keyframe for that
property we'll then drag that keyframe
down the timeline
to about one second let's make sure our
playhead is at the beginning of the
timeline
and we'll change the value of end to be
zero percent
and this will automatically create
another keyframe for us
cool so now we can preview our animation
we see the red stroke starts as nothing
and then draws itself
over the zero
great now let's make sure our edges of
the stroke are vertically straight
we'll press command r or control r on pc
to show the rulers
and then drag a guide out to help us
align things next we'll adjust our
anchor point tangents to try and
straighten things out a bit
it's okay if the red stroke itself looks
kinda weird
so long as it completely covers the zero
[Music]
now that we've straightened the edges
out let's smooth out the timing by
adding some easing we'll select the two
keyframes
and then press f9 to add easy ease
and we can see what that did by opening
the graph editor and making sure the
speed graph is selected
now when we play the animation you can
see that it starts slow
then speeds up toward the middle and
then slows down again
at the end but let's finesse that and
make it a bit more dramatic
we'll select the two keyframes in the
graph editor and then adjust the
tangents to make the curve more steep
which in turn will make the animation
more exaggerated
we can then shorten the time it takes
for the animation to finish
by dragging the second keyframe back in
the timeline
to around 10 frames
okay now we want to do the same thing on
the other side
so let's make a copy of our layer by
selecting it and pressing command
d or control d on pc to duplicate it
on that duplicate layer we'll right
click go to transform
and then select flip horizontal now we
have a mirrored layer of our animation
that we can line up to cover the other
side
but we want this side to start from the
bottom so
let's go back into transform and this
time choose flip
vertical we'll reposition it to make
sure the zero is entirely covered
there perfect
we're going to use this animation as a
mask to reveal the underlying zero
and to do that we need to first pre-comp
our two animation layers
so let's select shape layer 1 and shape
layer 2
right click and choose pre-compose
and we'll name it something obvious like
zero reveal animation
then click ok to create the new comp
cool
now our animation is all in one layer
and we can use it as a mask
we'll first select our underlying text
layer then we need to make sure that the
track math column is visible in the
timeline
and if it's not we can click the toggle
switches button at the bottom
to show it okay under track matte
we'll click the drop down menu on the
zero layer and choose alpha matte
that tells this layer to use the layer
above it as
a mask and when we play our animation
back we now see that the zero is
revealed by the mask
which makes it look like it draws itself
on the screen pretty cool
track mattes are a great tool for
animations like this where you want to
have one layer
reveal another okay now
let's animate the other numeral so we'll
duplicate the zero layer
double click to edit and change it to a
one
and then let's move that to the right to
reflect the design
and before we start let's look at the
animation again for reference
we see the one is formed from a
rectangle sliding in from right to left
and its serif flies out from behind it
okay so let's see how leo does this
we'll start by right clicking
on the one layer and choosing create
shapes from text
this makes a new shape layer with a path
that matches your text
now we don't need the original text
layer so let's delete that
we've got our one as a shape layer now
but to match the animation reference we
need to break it into two parts
and to do that let's duplicate the layer
and we'll name the top serif part
head and the bottom part stem
done let's start with the stem and to
stay focused we'll solo that layer
by clicking the circle icon next to the
eye symbol
in the layers panel to edit this shape
we're going to switch to the pen tool
options
and then look for the delete vertex tool
we can then remove
a couple of points to simplify the shape
we'll then twirl down the layer
properties a few steps until we see a
property named
path make sure the playhead is at the
beginning of the timeline
and then let's click the stopwatch next
to path to set a new keyframe and for
now
we'll move that key to frame 15. with
our playhead still at the start
we'll select the two points on the right
side of the shape and drag them to the
right
and off screen this will automatically
create a new keyframe where our playhead
is
and for now we're going to move this new
keyframe in the middle around frame 9.
next we're going to make a third
keyframe by selecting the points on the
left side of the shape
and moving them off screen too okay so
now we have three keyframes to work with
and if we preview the animation we see
that the shape
sort of stretches into position but it
needs some timey
refinement and it should also be a
rectangle
so let's get rid of that little angle at
the top
with our playhead at the first keyframe
we'll select the top left point
but when we move it the shape curves
because it's a bezier point
so let's go back to the pen tool and
this time choose the convert vertex tool
we'll then click the point to remove the
bezier and straighten it out
and with a little nudging we've now got
a rectangle
now let's do the same for the second
keyframe to make sure it remains a
rectangle
while it's in transition
looks good now let's work on the timing
we'll first select all three keyframes
and press f9 again to add
easy ease we'll then open the graph
editor and start to move things around a
bit
so let's do the same thing we did for
the zero by selecting all the keyframes
and dragging their tangents to make
steeper curves
and now when we play it back we can see
that the animation is much snappier
but there's a dip in movement during the
middle so let's smooth that out
we'll select the two middle points and
drag them up in the speed graph
there we go much smoother okay now let's
animate the serif
we'll make sure that the layer is
visible by clicking the solo button
and now we can see the entire numeral
and just like the stem we need to modify
this shape
so that it's only the serif we're
working with so
let's move our playhead to the middle
keyframe so we can see the rectangle
[Music]
we'll select the bottom two points and
then move them up to a line
with the serif
next we'll press p to twirl down the
position property of our selected layer
and let's set a position keyframe by
hitting the stopwatch
now let's move that keyframe down to
around frame 15
where the stem animation ends okay let's
move our playhead up
to around frame 8 select our serif
and move it to the right hiding it
within the rectangle
this creates the illusion of the serif
appearing from behind it
and since we only need to show the serif
toward the end of the rectangle
animation
we can trim the first part of that layer
and have it start at that first
keyframe to smooth out the timing let's
select these keys
hit f9 and add easy ease to them
and then lastly we'll open the graph
editor and this time we'll only drag the
right point
so that the animation starts quickly but
then finishes slowly
easing out and into its resting position
nice and smooth now let's move on to the
next part of the sequence
in the original animation we see that
after the zero and the one appear
the camera moves through them to find a
paragraph of text
it starts right justified but then
changes to be left justified
so let's see how leo achieved that
unique effect
now there are two ways we could approach
this we could type everything out in
illustrator
turn the text into shapes import them
into after effects
and then animate each word one by one
but that sounds like a lot of work
so let's take the quicker route we'll
start by grabbing the type tool
and setting our type right here in after
effects
and quick shout out to redcapmotion.com
which is leo's animation company
okay now we'll duplicate that layer and
use it to set our second line of text
now before we animate we need to make
sure our justification is correct
in this case we'll want to start with
the text justified
right so we'll go to window paragraph
and with our text layer selected choose
justify
right now we can align our layers on the
right side
and we're ready to animate
for the sake of time let's start with
one line
we'll twirl down the text layer
properties and under text
look for that animate button again the
one with a little arrow next to it
from that menu we'll choose position
this creates a new range selector
property that will let us animate the
text
within this layer next we'll drag out
some guides to help us position
and align things we know we want the
text to start justified on the right
and then move to be justified on the
left to make that happen
we'll look at our layer properties again
and under animator 1
range selector 1 we'll set a keyframe
for position
we'll then move our playhead down in the
timeline to around frame 15.
next we'll select our text layer again
and move it to the left so that it
aligns with our guide
and this will be the end position
great so we've got it moving right to
left now
let's make it move word by word
back in our layer properties we'll look
for range selector 1
twirl down its properties and animate
the end value
we'll make sure the playhead is in the
second position frame 15
and then we'll set a keyframe of 100
percent
now let's move our playhead back to the
start and change the value event
to zero percent so it starts at zero
and then changes to 100 over the course
of 15 frames
we can see that the text moves right to
left but now it's moving one letter at a
time
which is fun but we want to move whole
words
so under the range selector 1 properties
we'll twirl down the advanced settings
and change the based on value from
characters to words
now we've got each word moving from
right to left
and to smooth things out a little we'll
select the keyframes on position and
end hit f9 again and give them that easy
ease treatment
much better and the best part is that we
can reuse this animation for our second
line of text
so let's duplicate this layer and type
out our new text
cool we'll move that line down
beneath the first and there we go but
the two lines don't line up
at the end so we'll need to adjust the
second position keyframe on our new text
layer
so let's make sure the playhead is on
that keyframe and then change the
position value until it lines up on the
left
there we go and that's essentially how
that text animation works
leo's now going to show us how to take
the two animations we've built
and move a camera from one to the other
but to do that we'll need to make a new
composition
we'll go to composition new composition
and
let's call this one main comp it's where
our entire animation will live
we'll also need to make sure that it's
long enough to accommodate our camera
move
so let's go with 15 seconds next
we'll need to bring in our two other
compositions
the zero one animation and the paragraph
animation
so let's drag those two comps in from
the project tab
cool now let's make a camera in the menu
we'll go to layer
camera to create a new camera for our
scene
let's make sure the type is set to one
node camera and the preset
is 35 millimeters then we just hit ok
and we have ourselves a camera in order
for our layers to be seen by the camera
they need to be 3d so let's look for the
3d icon in our layer switches
it kind of looks like a small cube and
if it's not there we can always click
the toggle switches button to show it
we'll then click the empty square
beneath that cube for each layer to
enable
3d now when we switch to two views and
move our camera
we see that the text layer moves in 3d
space
as if our camera is tracking toward it
now we may need to switch back and forth
between views
so that we can see where things are in
3d space
if we solo our zero one layer and move
the camera close to it
we see that it looks pixelated and low
quality
which is not what we want so let's fix
that
to do that we'll need to check the
collapse transformation switch on that
layer
it's the small icon that resembles the
sun
but when we click on it the 3d effect is
lost
if we turn it off again the 3d effect
comes back
so we need to figure out something else
the thing is when you enable collapse
transformations on a composition like
r01 it tells the camera to look at each
layer
inside of that composition and treat
them as if they were on this current
timeline but when we open that
composition
we see that those layers do not have 3d
enabled
which means that's an easy fix turn on
3d for each of those layers
inside of our zero one composition
now when we go back to our main comp
with the camera
we see that the layers are back in 3d
space and they also remain
sharp when we get close to them problem
solved
and we'll do the same thing for our
paragraph composition
turn collapse transformations on both
the comp itself
and all of the layers inside of it while
also enabling 3d
on each of those layers it's important
to note that collapse transformations
works best on vector and text layers
it's designed to keep the resolution
intact but it doesn't work on raster
layers like
photos or videos alright now both of our
animations are in 3d space
and they'll keep their vector quality in
our main comp
let's move the paragraph animation back
in z space
away from our camera and we'll
reposition it
so that it appears directly behind the
zero
great now let's animate our camera we'll
twirl down the layer properties for our
camera
and set a keyframe for the position
making sure that it's after the zero one
animation has
completed next we'll move our playhead
down a few frames
and then move our camera in z space
through the zero
until we see the paragraph of text we
want the paragraph of text
to look like it's moving through fog and
kind of fading into view
so we'll slip the layer down in the
timeline and animate its opacity
so with the paragraph layer selected
we'll hit t to show the opacity property
it will set two keyframes the first will
be zero percent
and the second will be one hundred
percent right when the camera stops
there now it looks like it's fading in
with the camera move
but let's smooth things out so we'll
select our keyframes and press f9 again
to
add a little bit of easing we can also
adjust the camera's speed in the graph
editor
to make it a bit more dynamic
lastly let's add some depth of field
with our camera layer selected
we'll go to layer camera settings and
turn on
enable depth of field and let's try an
aperture of 15 to start
i think it looks pretty great when the
camera gets close to the zero
it blurs out creating this really nice
cinematic effect
and there we have it our finished
animation a big thank you to leo for
taking the time to share his animation
process with us
i think he did a fantastic job with the
video
look for a link in the description where
you can watch the full
typography manual animation it's really
good and you'll learn a lot from it
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one